so we've got this suit where basically
it's just like a coverall
so you'll see the sort of thing
forensics teams will wear it so that
they're completely covered from head to
toe it's it's protective gear basically
and what we're going to do now is take
you to X to one of our lecture theaters
to show you this suit in literally a
different light
Sam is using a laser dye laser dyes were
an invention of the late 1960s early 70s
until then you could only get lasers in
one color and that color was red so it's
rather like this laser here this is a
modern laser so it's not quite the same
color red and the old ones were really
big all right and then in the late 1960s
people discovered that if you took
certain sorts of dyes you could produce
lasers where you could change the color
they called it tuning the color though
this is something that's introduced into
the laser setup is called coumarin 540i
and you can see from the lid the color
the dyes they used had to be highly
fluorescent that means that they would
absorb light and then emit it again this
is the actual dye the dye crystals and
one done with this is actually dissolved
them in methanol and even without
putting UV on there you can see it's a
really nice vibrant yellow and like all
fluorescent molecules the one that Sam's
using which is called Qumran 5:40 a is a
molecule that has a lot of double bonds
next to each other this is what is
called a conjugated molecule and the
more double bonds that you have next to
each other within reason the more
strongly a molecule will absorb light if
Neil nel puts the UV light on the
solution there even without turning the
regular lights off in the lecture
theater you can see how brightly that's
shining right there
the laser dyes have an important
property that the exact wavelengths of
light they give out the color depends on
the surroundings of the molecules so you
can dissolve the laser dye in different
solvents to get slightly different
colors and there's a whole table here
talking about dissolving it into
from solvents so with the solution Neal
had the absolutely brilliant idea of
using it as a paint and so the reason
why I brought the suit in is because
we've painted a really nice design on it
and Neal is going to be our mannequin
for today and he's going to wear it and
show us exactly what it looks like need
to get Neal to actually turn right
around and then we'll kill the lights
and turn on the UV ready three two one
so what do you think Puma in normally if
it's in solution fluoresces with us of
yellow light but when it's in the solid
as Sam has done with her painting of the
skeleton then in the solid for some
reason the surrounding of the molecules
makes the light come out as blue laser
dyes are sold specifically for people to
use in lasers and nowadays lasers are
used in a huge variety of different
experiments
so it sounds specialized but a lot of
people want to buy these what Sam has
done is a very nice application of laser
dye but it's a very expensive way of
making something that fluoresces
especially if it's just fancy dress you
could get just the same result by
putting glue onto your suit and then
sticking washing powder on it because
most washing powders fluoresce quite
strongly but Sam has used laser dye
because Neil our technician is a
specialist in working with lasers so we
had some and it produces a much nicer
effect than you would have otherwise so
if you were doing an expensive taranta
at Racal production a really exciting
horrible movie or whatever you'd use a
laser dye but normally for fancy dress
it'd be far too expensive
okay Neil thanks mate
I've heard of days called Qumran I would
never have been able to say what its
real name is but Sam gave me a sheet of
paper with the proper name written on
and I read it out and I'll explain it as
we go along
it's two three six seven tetra hydro
that means there are four hydrogen atoms
nine trifluoromethyl that means it has a
CF 3 group one h 5 h 11 H 1 benzo parano
6 7 8
III Queen as Queen Queen o Lezyne 11 own
the last part I wouldn't understand at
all I could sort of have some guesses
it's easier just to look at the formula